[Music]
the loud house is now one of the most
popular cartoons on Nickelodeon and with
so many fans many people came up with a
lot of conspiracies and fan theories
make sure you watch this video and tell
Ian to know what would explain Lenny's
unusual behavior if you love the loud
house as much as we do don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
10 the loud house fan theories that will
blow your mind the adoption this one is
probably the most popular conspiracy all
across the loud house fandom don't you
think that the loud family is way too
big it is surprising to see that their
parents wanted to have so many babies
and the reason why they ended up with 11
kids might be simply because they really
wanted a baby boy they tried again and
again but always gave birth to a
daughter in this case they would have
stopped having babies after Lincoln but
the reason why they kept having kids
could be because the young boy was the
last one to be part of the family that's
because after having 10 daughters their
parents decided to adopt him
that would make sense as he doesn't look
like any other of his siblings and he
might have the same red hair as his
grandpa but it's probably simply because
his hair became white with time and he
wasn't born like that in ties that bind
Lincoln overheard his parents saying
that they might get rid of the white one
and his father didn't even think that he
was his they were just talking about
ties and Lincoln misunderstood this
conversation but it still could be a
clue that our favorite character hasn't
always been part of the family we think
that this fan theory totally makes sense
the orphanage another fan came up with a
really similar theory they don't really
have anything to back this up but it's
still fun to think about this they think
that the loud family is actually an
orphanage so not only Lincoln but all
the kids would be adopted that would
explain why their personalities are so
different and why there are so many of
them after all when you look at the age
difference it's hard to believe that
their mothers belly managed to carry a
child or two almost every year or for so
many years however there are many things
that could debunk this theory
first it's totally possible to have 11
kids and it was not unusual at all
decades ago they might be different but
we think that every kid wants to stand
out from their family and when you see
their look it's totally possible that
they have the same parents most of them
have blond or brown hair if we saw many
children of different origins we could
say that they might not have the same
parents but as you can see they are all
white and they also have really similar
first names so unless these parents only
wanted white kids with a name that
starts with the letter L we think that
it's probably not an orphanage no matter
what it was fun to think about this
the ghosts this one is a dark theory but
we still think that it could be
interesting a fan imagines that many of
the loud house siblings actually passed
away and Lincoln is the only one who
could see all these girls haunting him
according to this fan Lily was never
born because there was a miscarriage
Lisa didn't experiment on herself and
something terrible happens when exploded
Lola and Lana both died in the same year
and on the same day and this is why they
are twin ghosts Lola ran away from home
to become a real princess but no one
knows what really happened to her and
Lana got a disease from all the frogs
and the weird creatures she played with
Lucy was possessed by a demon Lynn
injured herself while playing sports and
she was really desperate because she
couldn't compete anymore LuAnn took a
joke a little bit too far and Luna had
an accident at night after a concert
lynnie stupidity explained her death and
Lori had a car accident none of this
makes sense but a fan still took the
time to write about this this could
explain why these kids never grow up we
don't believe in this theory because we
have absolutely no proof but we still
have to thank this fan for entertaining
us this smart boy
after watching the butterfly effect a
fan came up with a really interesting
theory if you don't remember this
episode Lincoln made a little mistake
and decided not to tell his sister Lisa
then he imagined all the worst things
that could happen because of this Lori
thought her boyfriend cheated on her
Lisa gave up science and got a job at a
gas station Lynn was kicked off her
sports team because she failed school
and so on and one of the weirdest thing
that happens is that Linney had a
concussion after being hit on the head
and this is what made her smarter she
first said that everyone knows an object
falling at a velocity of 9.8 meters per
second squared will result in a
temporary loss of consciousness then she
told Lisa that she did her super hard
math equation in an incorrect order
because she didn't get why she
multiplied her Z polynomials before
solving her non negative exponents we
don't understand this either
anyway if you watch the whole episode
you know that Lincoln just imagined this
but that would mean that he knew all
about the things that his sister when he
said which would actually make him
smarter than his little sister Lisa
that's a really interesting theory and
we're just waiting for more proofs that
Lincoln is actually really smart the
manipulation we all have to admit that
Linney is not the smartest sibling out
there at 16 years old you think that she
would be really wise but her little
sister Lisa is actually much more
intelligent at only 4 years old the
young girl already won a Nobel Prize
while Linney doesn't understand the
rules of the game Marco Polo she cannot
chew gum and walk at the same time and
her favorite color is zebra
but what if we've been wrong during all
this time what if Lindy was actually
incredibly smart a fan thinks that she
has been manipulating her siblings
during all this time by pretending that
she was dumb and we actually already saw
that she was very intelligent for
example in it's a loud loud loud house
she knew how to open a chest with a hair
clip none of the other characters could
do that then and one flew over the loud
house she knew what the normal
temperature is for humans and had many
other good ideas like using the dog door
in the butterfly effect we could even
see that Linney was smarter than Lisa
this was only what Lincoln imagined but
maybe he wasn't really far off from the
truth however this man didn't explain
why Linney would want everyone to think
that she was dumb maybe life is simpler
when people don't count on you when it
comes to helping you do your homework
the money it's really surprising to see
a family with 11 kids many parents would
admit that it's already hard to take
care of one child so we don't understand
how the loud parents deal with many of
them some fans had a theory to explain
this
the LAV family is actually really rich
after all not a lot of people can afford
a house with so many rooms for all the
children and we're not even talking
about all the food the clothes and all
the other stuff that they have to buy
for example in the greenhouse Lincoln
found out that his family was using an
incredible amount of electricity for
their everyday needs he was so afraid of
being an outcast that he forced his
family to go green this is why he cut
off more and more electrical appliances
and the girls had to wear potato sacks
we think that this is what they would
look like if they were not rich the
reason why they don't live fancy is that
there are too many kids in this family
but if Lincoln were an only child he
would have 10 times more things than he
already has and that would also explain
why we don't really see their parents
they are working all the time we will
have to thank these fans for coming up
with this because it totally makes sense
the mental disorder here is another
really dark theory so if you don't like
things like this you might want to skip
this one according to one fan only
Lincoln Lucy and Lilly really exists all
the other siblings are just a delusion
that the boy made up in his mind to feel
better according to this crazy theory
the loud parents were really mean to
their kids this is the reason why you
don't see their face
Lincoln hates them so much that he
doesn't want to talk about them his only
companion used to be Lucy and the reason
why she is gothic and looks depressed is
that this is her way to cope with what
is happening to her family the reason
why so many episodes revolve around Lucy
is that she is one of the only three
children who are actually real she also
shows a lot of affection for him because
they are going through this together
Lilly is new to the family and she is
making everyone's life better and
happier but the other sisters are all
just a coping mechanism for Lincoln
instead of facing the traumatizing truth
and admitting that his parents are
terrible he created a lot of stories
with him and ten other siblings just to
feel better about his life we think that
this theory is crazy and it doesn't make
sense at all but it was still enough to
entertain us for a minute the favorite
this fan theory is actually really
simple and this is why it makes a lot of
sense
is simply that Lincoln is the favorite
sibling in the loud family we already
agree with this but let's hear what this
fan has to say before we talk about
which sibling could be transgender when
you start watching the cartoon you can
see that the story is from Lincoln's
point of view as he tries to survive
with ten sisters as a series goes on
it's clear that no matter what happens
they will always love him and would do
anything for him after all they were all
there to help him when they thought that
he was bullied or after breaking
something he owned they also made a huge
effort to make him a part of their
favorite activities even if Lincoln
wasn't really interested after all you
don't often see the sisters helping each
other and Lincoln is the one they look
out for and the reason why they love him
so much is that he loves them too and he
always did his best to accommodate
everyone even when everything was just
chaotic he's their only brother and they
have to take good care of him this
theory is really simple but it makes a
lot of sense so we actually believe it
the transgender and here comes one of
the weirdest theories on the show and we
were surprised to learn that it could
actually make sense after all we know
that the characters of the loud house
are really open-minded as we can see a
gay couple in this cartoon and some fans
think that the show is so progressive
that it even features a transgender kid
it would be Lin who is a transgender
girl it would mean that she was born a
boy but decided to live like a woman
because she felt like she was born in
the wrong body the first thing that made
fans think this with when she gave
Lincoln a jockstrap that used to belong
in her sleuth or Consequences you
probably know that only boys wear these
so Lin might have something more
masculine to protects between her legs
fans also think that the reason why she
doesn't have breasts yet is that she
takes hormones to keep herself from
becoming a grown up man and it slows
down her development
she is also named Lin jr. which is
usually a name that a father gives their
oldest boy people also know that the
reason why there is one syllable in her
name and like her other sisters is that
she changed it when she decided to be a
girl we have to admit that we don't
really believe in this theory but it's
still fun to see all the proofs
the autistic child many people have been
wondering why Linney is so naive
one of the theories that we talked about
is that she is actually really smart but
just playing dumb for fun and another
one is that she might be autistic before
you tell us that you don't believe in
this theory you have to know that there
are a lot of different people on the
spectrum and some of them can be
high-functioning or they worked hard to
learn how to look normal be an autistic
doesn't make anyone dumb sometimes it's
simply harder for them to understand
social cues or communicate with others
and they can also tend to be obsessed
with some things and follow a routine
there are many other symptoms but it's
not the same for everyone
some fans notice that Linney has
difficulty paying attention and she is
always holding her hands in front of her
body which is what some people who have
autism tend to do however many people
prove that there are many other reasons
why Linney is probably not autistic
social interactions don't seem difficult
to her as she is really comfortable with
her family she also has no problem
understanding how her siblings are
feeling so it was fun to think about
this but Linney is probably not a person
with autism did you hear about any other
fan theories don't be tried to tell us
what it is in the comment section down
below we'd love to hear what you think
and that's it for 10 the loud house fan
theories that will blow your mind for
more theories like this make sure you
watch 10 mistakes in the loud house you
might have missed thanks for watching
[Music]